if I will accept the Westminster has got
a little bit too much challenge too much
resignations would you accept that there
isn't enough of that in Hollywood that
there is simply not enough debate
there's not enough testing I mean here
there's barely a day passes about
somebody calling for the Prime Minister
resign I get that that's too much but
the fact that Ash Reagan was the first
minister to resign in Scotland for 14
years the fact that there is the
Hollywood committee really doesn't have
the teeth to challenge the government
don't you think there could be a little
bit more Scot on Scot you know action in
Hollywood governments need opposition
they need scrutiny they need an
independent civil service and they needs
people resigning now and again